[Musik]
damit herzlich willkommen hier heute zu
einer neuen folge von promiflash ihrem
beschissen strafen bedingt heute meine
sehr verehrten zuschauer beschäftigen
uns mit dem reichen leben von crafter
kay luca und kraftwerke nok hat über 3,4
millionen abonnenten auf youtube das
heißt er hat circa 40 millionen euro auf
dem konto heute schauen wir uns mal
seine villa an das mache ich überhaupt
herzlich willkommen hier zu einem
heutigen hier zu einem heutigen video
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einem
neuen video auf seinem kanal da kann man
da kann man mal ganz kurz ein bisschen
klatschen ganz ganz ganz ganz viele
leute haben in die kommentare
geschrieben hey lucas später mal wieder
simmons deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
ich spiel mal wieder sims klingt ja sehr
logisch ihr kennt ja noch hier unsere
familie pizza das hier ist unser haus
hier ist der warum haben wir eigentlich
kein auto das hier sind unsere ganzen
nachbarn wir haben keinen nachbarn mir
keiner nehmen uns wohnen will doch ich
würde sagen wir schauen erst mal was sie
überhaupt updater luca sitzt am stinkt
der so krass ist es auch besser so mein
freund r b
[Musik]
luca ist in der badewanne doch während
luca hier sein bat genießt würde ich
sagen schauen wir mal bei lukas freunden
vorbei ich weiß nicht wer von euch neu
bei diesem mysims projekte sage ich mal
aber das hier ist meine freundin bianca
heinicke irgendwie ist es mittlerweile
ein bisschen komisch weil die beiden
beziehungsweise nur baby hat ja
eigentlich ein kind ich habe noch kein
kind luca hat sein bart beendet ist aber
irgendwie denkt an müll
warum schreist du so alter luca denkt an
müll setzt sich am pc und spielten aber
was ist falsch mit diesen menschen die
bibi pennt auf jeden fall den ganzen tag
das können und die echte wie sein dann
haben wir hier vorne unseren garten also
erst mal auf promi vielleicht
zurückzukommen das reiche leben von luca
cache von crafter heute schauen wir uns
mal seine seele an in der er immer zu
hause die kostet nämlich 14
eine menge groß viel geld das hier ist
das haus von luca elcom crafter es
beinhaltet einen riesigen pool der um
die ecke geht er hat einen tollen
draußen grill bereich er wohnt direkt an
einem see hatte ruhige hill verhältnisse
um ihn herum denn es existieren keine
nachbarn und einen blick ins innere
inneres des hauses werfen wir nun mal
zusammen wir haben hier ein unfassbar
teures wohnzimmer mit unfassbar teuren
möbeln wir haben hier ein unfassbar
teures bad mit einer porzellan gold
diamant badewanne hier haben wir das
arbeitszimmer von luca lkw konkreter
hier sehen wir einen brandneuen apple
imac 14.000 euro hier sehen wir luca von
crafter der übelste voll spaß ich meinen
laufschritt wie sehe ich da eigentlich
gerade überhaupt aus hier sehen wir
porzellan geschirr von der oma vererbt
worden aus dem jahr 1803 und 1000 es
kostet vier millionen euro was natürlich
auch in dem
fehlen darf ist ein model bianca rettig
ist es nicht so schön er hat auf jeden
fall auch eine freundin mit der er sich
diese tolle schlafzimmer teils nebenan
haben wir den essbereich an mein ohr
juckt entschuldigung dann kommen wir nun
auch zur küche die könnte jetzt ganz
normal die care einbauküche drei euro ja
meine damen und herren
falls ihr euch fragt was in dieser zins
folge hier gerade überhaupt los ist
keine ahnung ehrlich gesagt ich habe
irgendwie so ein artikel gelesen über
die reichsten deutschen youtuber und da
war ich auch irgendwie in den top 10 mit
dabei und auch dass ich ein krasses team
hinter mir hätte hey danke nochmal team
das immer hinter mir steht ihr seht ihr
ein komplettes team was mir bei allem
möglichen immer hilft wehrheim
mein name ist lukas alles alleine
dastand irgendwie alle youtuber die in
dieser liste sind machen ihre videos
auch nicht alleine und haben ein team
und alles möglich ich hab gar nicht da
stand halt noch irgendwie wie viel ich
verdienen würde ich glaube die hat über
sowas ähnliches auch die tage in video
hochgeladen also fand ich sehr sehr sehr
sehr mysteriös und die sich in um die
summe her genommen haben aber luca luca
sitzt die ganze zeit vom pc und babys
es ist acht uhr morgens aufgestanden das
heißt ich kann die uhr wieder normal war
bei gott ich will ja nicht wie beim
baden zu sehen vorne haben wir irgendwie
eine frau beim rennen ich würde sagen
dass der luca die einfach mal an
quatscht an isar
läuft ihre runden auf und ab ich weiß
jetzt nicht wie luca da vielleicht mal
hingehen kann oder so kommt der bucher
vielleicht auch schon raus da kommen
sogar angefragt haben sie mal durch luca
geholt sie einkommen brudy kommen hier
hin gehen kommen wir schaffen das kommen
wo die kommt laufen hinterher das ist
doch echt das rennen der bescheuerten
reihe laufen einfach komplett bescheuert
also ich an dieser tötet ihr das gewesen
ist einfach weggeputzt worden
naja egal dann freuen wir uns das leben
mit meinen freunden reden und eine
freundschaft darum wollen sie die
plötzlich weg florian lehrer florian
heller könnte tatsächlich das kind von
der 1
[Musik]
hey hey luca spiel mal wieder slim ist
ganz toll mit anderen leuten
interagieren ja ich kann das aber nicht
weil ich gerade aber luca macht den
jetzt raus du wir erwarten ja einfach ab
und mal schauen
tipps auf dem handy rum hp halo das
macht auch gehen kann ich freundlich
bekommt er freundlich vorstellen der
sieht exakt aus wie drake also der typ
in dem wir hier reden der heißt
tatsächlich bob and ethics pfannkuchen
machen ich übersetze euch mal die
unterhaltung von den beiden für deine
leistung drake also dein neues album hat
mich echt hammer da kann man wirklich
nur sagen mach weiter so mit deiner
musik finde ich wirklich klasse was du
da machst was du da aus einer schublade
zauber seiner bilder du fliegst
wahrscheinlich auch zu konzerten oder so
wichtig kenne auch wenn schlechtes
wetter ist trittst du da dann auf find
ich wirklich ein mega gut wie du das
machst du da muss ich sagen da heule ich
jedes mal wenn ich dich auftreten sehe
wie ein feuerball war nicht darum im
publikum vielleicht hast du ja schon mal
leute da gerade nackt durchs bild oh
mein gott leute diese kleines kind ich
glaube ich in die hose geschissen hat er
das läuft aber die gleise wenn paar
sekunden später ok kind wurde überfahren
aber wir haben immer noch dreck hier
vorne und du willst also dieser luca von
youtube schon auf video von ihr gesehen
ja ich mache so komme die sache nicht
lange da ganz gerne meinen videos bin
also ein bisschen lustig unterwegs tja
das ist ein richtiger star auf dieser
plattform
ja genau das kann ich auf jeden fall
recht geben mein lieber drake ich mach
das schon ordentlich cash mit ich habe
gerade ja ich habe gerade ein bisschen
musik gefurzt finma zur sonne geflogen
weil ich so heiß bin du kennst ja okay
ich gehe einmal alles staubsaugen jetzt
allein in meinem schmetterling ja
kann sich das schon
jetzt liegt auch noch meinen kopf durch
oder war es also ja real kaum freunde
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich wusste nicht
was ich in sims machen soll als mir
leute geschrieben haben hey luca nimm
doch mal wieder sims auf das war voll
cool auf die unterhaltung nachgestellt
aus
ich habe jetzt mir auch noch addons für
sims gekauft ich habe mir beispielsweise
hunde und katzen gekauft verschiedene
andere sachen die man auf jeden fall im
sommer was machst du denn hier draußen
ja ich habe gerade track getroffen
dieser dieser musiker kennst du den oma
da der macht schallplatten cds alles auf
spotify neuerdings der facebook spiele
ich aber nicht so gut ich verlasse mich
alle bruder geht weg
das ist tim's mit mir ich würde sagen
wir gehen jetzt einfach mal zudem
hingestellt uns mal grob vor ich bin in
meiner besten zeit panzer gefahren hat
dabei dann immer richtig schöner den
abend gegessen auch ich mal gern ja das
mag wirklich das sagen sich viele was
macht baby davor und wer ist das bitte
also die hier ehrlich gesagt sehr
schlecht aus lucy black hallo lustig
vorstellen lucy hallo ich bin colin sehr
gut luca so schadet man gesprächig er
könnte ja mal bei dir ins bett mit kaum
das geht nicht da spiele standen mit der
mit der bbc ich da immer das wirklich
machen
aber du bist doch du bist doch du bist
jetzt wichtige baby gewisser
baseballspieler herzen fernsehen ja und
du bist ja du du bist ja diese lucy
black di luci black genau die bist du
die gerade bei mir im haus
ich habe bei meinem knast und hat daran
stellen um das hat uns stark gemacht
habe ich mal plastikdosen habe ich da
getrieben
habt ihr alle kraft getreten mega
kracher das gemeingut
tapezieren
die bläck fööss über egon und luca geht
ins bett
was macht ihn herzlich
[Musik]
auch die partie ich dachte jetzt wird
die bürger welche aber dann ist ja alles
cool also die lucy black ist hier der
luca muss war übel zu pissen und alles
aber geht es erstmal panel und die bibel
sitzt jetzt bei mir am pc also dieser
haushalt meine damen und herren das ist
menschlich sind ziemlich abstoßend
an der stelle wird das heutige video ist
allerdings ob meine damen und herren so
unfassbar viele leute haben die
kommentare geschrieben luca ladner
wieder sims 4 hoch deswegen hier ein
neues 4 video von mir soll ich eventuell
in einer woche neuen part hochladen
meine damen und herren der last 40.000
likes da es ist eine sehr sehr sehr sehr
große zahl aber wenn ihr unbedingt
wollte haye lukas ist geil du bist geil
ich weiß ich bin ich geil aber wenn ihr
so wollt 40.000 like schreibt er die
kommentare was immer ihr wollt alltag
[Musik]